I warmly welcome you to Friedrich Nietzsche,
one of the great European
philosophers. Today we are dealing
with the famous "will to power" and Nietzsche’s
great vision of the overman. And you will see
that Nietzsche has numerous ideas that
are of burning topicality. And already in 1882
he formulated a small sentence
which has acquired great fame.
It's very short and I’ve brought it with me
For you: "God is dead".
This little phrase is known everywhere nowadays,
not just in Europe, but also in America. "God is dead!".
Everyone thinks ‘I've heard this phrase before’.
Very few people know that this sentence
came from Nietzsche, but
it is well known. It spread around the world
like wildfire because Nietzsche
in saying this, brought something to expression
that was to become a big problem
in the next few centuries for the
entire world, or at least the western world.
By saying "God is dead" Nietzsche does not mean
just any event, i.e. that God died suddenly.
He is speaking of a process. He says: "What I’m telling
is the story of the next two centuries.
I am describing what is to come, what has to come:
namely, the advent of nihilism."
So what he says – "God is dead" – means:
This is about the history of the next two
centuries. He said that around 1880. If you
extrapolate 1980, 2080, that's a process that's
extends to our own times and it's the process
of the rise of nihilism and mass atheism.
And if we're honest, up to half a million people
are actually leaving the churches every year.
Even in this year of Luther’s anniversary
Many people have left and one has to assume
that in just a few years the vast majority of the
European population will no longer be in the
church. From that point of view, Nietzsche’s prediction
was of course quite accurate. Part of the reason why
this is happening, he says, is of course
the emerging natural sciences. You have to
remember that Nietzsche's contemporary was
Charles Darwin, who was the first to say that we are
not all descended from Adam and Eve,
but rather we are higher mammals that have
slowly emerged through evolution via the apes,
via the hominids. But it wasn't just Darwin. Numerous
scientists have shaken and shattered the old
religious worldview in which we felt safe and secure
for thousands of years. It was a time of enormous
disruption: in medicine, in physics,
in all areas. To take just medicine:
It used to be thought that the plague, cholera,
these serious diseases, especially the plague,
were the work of the devil, or rather
ia punishment from God. But even before 1900,
a Russian scientist said: "No, it's
just a bacterial infection" and everything
was put to the test. At that time there was a
big breakthrough. More and more doubts were raised,
not only about Adam and Eve, about the immaculate
conception, about the whole story of creation - but
in the end also about God himself.
And now Nietzsche says: "Where has God gone?"
And then something exciting happens. He says:
"We killed him, you and I! We are all his killers!"
And what he means by that is very simple: it wasn't
just Darwin and the natural scientists
who killed God with their new theories explaining
the world. No, we all did, because we withdrew
the power that gives God existence,
because we no longer believed in him in that way.
Nietzsche was the first post-modern
thinker. He even wrote a book
called The Antichrist. He was an atheist,
a committed atheist, but he was also the first
post-modern thinker. Why post-modern?
What does post-modern mean? What does modern mean?
By modernity we generally understand
this great awakening of the Enlightenment,
when the natural sciences began, when
the French Enlighteners – Rousseau, Voltaire, Montesquieu –
suddenly demanded the separation of powers, asked
"Who shall rule the people if not the people?" and so on.
That was a great awakening,
the Enlightenment – or, as the French say,
“illumination” –
means that the light of reason
should go everywhere and should
illuminate and dispel, so to speak, superstition, belief,
myth and ancient worldviews. That was the modern age.
Nietzsche is the first post-modern thinker.
Saying that is no longer enough for him. The
Enlightenment was also very critical. Kant, Locke, Hume
and all the Enlightenment thinkers were
also critical of religion, but it is not enough
for Nietzsche to criticize that. He says:
the real question that Man will have
to ask himself in the next few centuries
is a completely different one. What happens
when the last human has stopped
believing in God? What happens then?
That interested him. And then he says - quote:
"Since the belief has ceased that a god guides the fate
of the world on a large scale,
people themselves have to set goals
that encompass the whole earth.
Herein lies the tremendous task."
So if we are no longer secure
in the religious worldview that life is a task that
we have to fulfill in order to get to paradise,
if that no longer supports us, then
we have to take on this task ourselves.
Humans themselves must now
give themselves global goals that span the entire world
in order to shape the future. And now, he says - and
that's why he's considered a post-modern thinker - we
have a big problem. He says that
people aren't ready for it. Because,
his contemporaries, he says,
when he looks at them, all he can do is
shake his head. As soon
as God is dead, they fall into belief in false idols
and new idols are erected. One of those idols,
he says, is nationalism and the form of this that
especially concerned him: the German one. It started then,
you know, the founding of the Reich in 1870 and everything.
The German nationalism and supremacism of that time
got on his nerves. If there is any nation, he said,
that can be proud of what they are,
patriotic about their culture can be proud of,
then ist is the French. And then he says here,
"Is there any thought behind this herd nationalism? What
value could there be in stirring up this crude selfishness
now that everything points to
greater and common interests?"
And it always annoyed him, these fraternities,
the student movements, these marching singers,
the fuss with the "Kaiser",
it got on his nerves. Because he says
it's just a new idol. God is dead,
we no longer have meaning through religion.
So now we try to create the meaning we lack
by saying “we're German” or “we're French” or
“we’re English”. And that's wrong. The next big idol,
he says, and this is even worse,
is that people now derive their self-worth,
after God is dead, from
being higher than others and thereby
feel, even within the age of nihilism,
a little more important than others. And the
racists are always looking for some group.
For example, the anti-Semites. And then Nietzsche says:
"The anti-Semites cannot forgive the Jews for the fact that
the Jews have brains - and money: anti-Semitism -
a name for those who have ‘come off badly’.
There is no more brazen and stupid gang in Germany
than these anti-Semites."
I mean, Nietzsche scolded many things,
but he despised anti-Semites in particular. He
was friends with Wagner for a while
before they naturally fell out. And
there he also writes: "Lately Wagner has been
unbearable. This constant anti-Semitism,
he's almost as bad as my sister." Because
that was deeply repugnant to him. Because he
said "God is dead – so now we have to derive
our self-worth from something else and it can’t be
that you derive self-worth from something like that.
As you can see, Nietzsche was anything but
a Nazi. Any appropriation in this direction
is not possible in view of these statements
by Nietzsche. The only thing that Hitler really had
from Nietzsche and could copy one to one
was Nietzsche's original walking stick.
After Nietzsche
was already dead, Nietzsche's sister gave it
to him, gave Hitler this walking stick,
but Hitler almost certainly never read Nietzsche.
Then Nietzsche goes on to say:
Another great idol is also there now, which may
play a role for centuries to come. He was incredibly
farsighted politically and he says: It's socialism.
Socialism. - You know, 1848, Karl Marx,
Communist Manifesto, he of course
noticed this movement, although
there was not yet any existing socialist state,
but his prognosis was already negative at that time.
He says: "Socialism covets an abundance
of state power such as only despotism has ever had.
Yes, it surpasses everything that has come before it
by striving for the formal annihilation of the individual,
and it drives the word justice like a nail into the head
of the half-educated masses to rob them completely
of their minds." So he also criticized socialism as a new
idol, because he says that the socialists are striving
for despotic state power,
in which only one party gets to govern and
the party is always right and
all individuals are brought into line.
And then he says that socialism cannot work
because people are not equal.
We are not all the same.
Individualism was very important
to Nietzsche. And he says that if we
give everyone the same amount of money, if everyone
is co-ordinated and regimented, that can't go well.
This abolition of the individual will take revenge.
That is why socialism is also a
new religion for him. He says well,
God is dead, now people don't believe
they're going to paradise. So what happens?
They are promised a
workers' paradise and a worldly promise of salvation
is given instead of the metaphysical promise of
salvation. But that doesn't work either.
And he says it's also bad
to hold on to these idols.
And the fourth great idol,
ladies and gentlemen, what else will that be? It is
the one we believe in today.
Yes, capitalism. Quote: "The commercial man
examines all that is created from the viewpoint
of supply and demand, in order to set
a thing’s worth and value for himself. This,
made a characteristic of an entire culture,
is what you people of the
next century will be proud of. "
This is remarkable, because at that time the
beginnings of globalization and capitalism were
already there, but not yet fully developed.
But he says that the “commercial man”,
the businessman or the capitalist or entrepreneur,
measures everything only according to
the value of the goods on the market according to supply
and demand. He rents out an apartment
at the highest price at which he can
still finds tenants for it. And
everything is determined only by supply and demand.
There are no other principles
of justice any more. And everyone lives by this principle.
And there is a
new idolatry. People will only measure
themselves according to
how far they’ve “made it”, how rich they are,
and so on, and worship filthy Mammon
i.e. money. And this is just as much a god
or idol worship as socialism and
nationalism. And these idols have a chance,
says Nietzsche, because they comfort us,
because it is not easy to endure nihilism,
the cold breath
of nihilism, after God is dead.
So we console ourselves with these idols.
And now he asks the question:
How? "How do we console ourselves,
we, the murderers of all murderers?
Shouldn't we become gods ourselves?"
That is now
the central question. This is a
post-modern question. How
are we to go on, now that God
has lost his power to create
being, and now that ever fewer people go to church
and get their whole world view from it? What’s
next? How do we console each other,
the murderers of all murderers? Shouldn't we
become gods ourselves? And here
his answer is a resounding "yes".
We must now take the fate of this world
into our own hands. We must now
take on this great task. The only problem is -
and this is why we’ve repeatedly mentioned the “idols” -
we're not even able to do it yet. Not yet, anyway.
We don't yet have the strength to take
on this task. But we must get there
because: "All gods are dead, now we want
the overman to live." And that's
what we're going to deal with now. What is this
overman? Where should we go after Nietzsche?
But you see how up-to-date this actually is.
He's already very close to us and that's
why he's the postmodern thinker.
Well - already as a 25-year-old,
as a young guy, Nietzsche found the key
to understanding the whole world, or
he believed that he’d discovered it. Do you know where?
Where did he find that key? Ironically,
in ancient Greek tragedy. He says
these old things, these old Greek tragedies,
recognized what it is to be human and
what the whole world is all about. Because
in these old tragedies there are always
only two major principles: the hero
who fights and acts and is always torn
between the Dionysian and
the Apollonian principle. So I have another quote
with me. He says: "There are two states in
which art, i.e. the theater itself, appears like a force
of nature in people: on the one hand as a compulsion
to have a vision, on the other hand as a compulsion to
engage in an orgy." Nietzsche says that these two
principles exist in each of us - not only in the hero
of ancient Greece.
I'll explain this briefly. One is the Apollonian
principle. This is what he calls the
compulsion to have a vision. So, we want to have
visions. We want to plan the world. We want to
shape the world. He names this principle after
the god Apollo
Apollo, a Greek god, was the god
of future planning, also of prophecy,
the god of reason. He was the radiant
god and the founder of cities. In a word, he was
a doer, we would say today, but also a thinker
who planned and structured. So the
Apollonian principle stands for the rational,
Planning element in Man. But also there
is Dionysus. Everyone probably knows
the good god of drunkenness, i.e. the god
of wine, not of drunkenness – of wine, yes, and
of drunkenness only if you overdo it. And
of course Dionysus also stands for creativity,
for the chaotic, for the purely emotional,
for passion, for passionate knowledge.
In the pictures of him he is always
with women and wine. And these two principles fight
against each other in every human being - even
in classical tragedy. So it's often the case
that we plan and do something and at the
last moment we do it differently for
some reason. We know what is reasonable
and that what we are doing now is unreasonable
but we do it anyway, and so you have to
imagine that the Apollonian always tries
to shape the world first and then
the Dionysian makes everything dance again.
An example is 'Oedipus' by Sophocles, a very
old tragedy. Oedipus always tries to do
everything right. He arrives in a town
where there is a despotic king and he
fights him, kills him, falls in love with
the queen, marries her – and at some point realizes
that he has married his own mother
He didn't even know that because he was
abandoned as a child – and then of course
everything is in chaos again. That's how you
have to imagine it. And Nietzsche says, that's
life. The Greeks realized how our life
really is. And we need 'amor fati',
the love of fate and that means we never
get out of suffering completely. But
we have to accept these two
principles, that's the way it is. But
a big mistake was already made in ancient times.
With Euripides, who was also a great tragic author,
the Dionysian element suddenly disappeared,
was suppressed, no longer really respected.
Because in classical tragedy there was always a chorus,
the lamentation chorus. This chorus always represented
feelings and the Dionysian. And
what was on the stage was more
Apollonian. And at the latest under Euripides
the chorus was omitted. The Dionysian played
less and less of a role. The rational man became
stronger and stronger in antiquity and
this went even further with Plato and his main
character Socrates. All of a sudden the view was that
the Dionysian is bad and evil and that we have to turn
ourselves upwards, toward the idea of justice,
of truth, of beauty. And then suddenly being human
was completely redefined. "Happiness", says
Nietzsche, "just means you have
to imitate Socrates and create a
daylight against dark desires, the daylight
of reason. Every yielding to the instincts,
to the unconscious, leads us down." And
then, Nietzsche says, something happens:
a mind-body separation. The physical,
the Dionysian, our lust, our sensuality
become evil. That leads down. The spirit, the reason,
the intellect, that leads us upward.
And that was a fatefully bad development,
because, as he then puts it:
"The moralism of the Greek philosophers
from Plato onwards is pathological."
This trend becomes even more sick and pathological with the
emergence of Christianity because Christianity is still
more hostile to the body. I don't know how many of
you were raised Catholic.
We're in Bavaria. I learned during puberty that
you shouldn't think unchastely,
which of course no pubescent person can hep but do. And Nietzsche says that with
Christianity this developed in a fatal way. Because
in ancient times there was “the wise man and
the fool”. And the wise man developed
the soul upwards and the fool just
followed his desires. Plato says that the latter is
like the existence of a duck. One just eats and excretes
and enjoys it. But in Christianity it gets much
worse. Because there, there is a bipolarity.
The bipolarity in Christianity is between good and evil
and one can fall entirely under the sway of evil and the Devil
or one can turn oneself toward God. And the
body, bodily nature, temptation, these are
for the Christian just secondary things. And Nietzsche
criticizes Christianity on four grounds. First:
"I condemn Christianity, I raise against the
Christian church the most terrible
of all accusations that an accuser has ever uttered.
It has made a worthlessness out of every value,
a lie out of every truth." In his remarks
he also explains that in Christianity’s main symbol,
this God on the cross, that is, this Jesus, the
suffering one, everything has been lost that
is actually important for us
humans, namely courage,
heroic struggles, standing up for oneself. This
"turn the other cheek",
he says, that was a mistake, that was a
mistake. Secondly, he says that the pity
that Christianity propagates, so to speak,
is not good either. "Pity," he says,
"is a waste of feelings, a parasite
harmful to moral health,
it cannot possibly be a duty to increase the
evils in the world". For very often, he says,
out of pity we give alms and other things besides
and thereby prolong the suffering of people
who might otherwise rebel and do something
that would change society. But no,
we all support this compassion which does
not solve any problems. And compassion,
he says, can also be a sign of contempt
which is implied in someone’s feeling sorry for you.
So pity is, for Nietzsche, something very bad.
Incidentally, he also says:
"Beggars should be abolished, because you
always feel bad when you walk past a
beggar. Either you give him something,
then you feel bad, or you
don't give him anything, then you also feel bad”.
So definitely, pity, that wasn't for him. His third
major criticism of Christianity was the following:
It gives rise to an entirely new type of human being.
He says: "Perhaps up to now there has been no
more dangerous ideology, no greater nonsense
in psychological matters, than this will to the good:
it has given rise to the most disgusting type,
the most unfree human being, the “yes-man”,
people have been taught that it’s only as “yes-men” that
they’re on the right path to divinity." You know that
humility is very important in Christianity and that
one is constantly committed to doing good,
because life is a test, a task. And he says that
in the end there arise thereby “yes-men”, hypocrites,
and this doesn't only apply to Christianity.
You know, regardless of whether it's in Islam,
there's prayer and bowing down to the ground
or the Christians who kneel down, he says,
there results a certain kind of person.
He doesn't think that's healthy. And the last
thing he criticizes is the sentence: "If
thine eye offends thee, pluck it out”.
The Christian who follows that advice
and thinks he has killed his sensuality
is wrong. This sensuality lives on in an uncanny
vampiric way and torments him in
disgusting disguises." So Nietzsche says that
we can’t just live in a purely Apollonian way
and completely suppress the Dionysian.
Here, by the way, he anticipates
something that Sigmund Freud later
said. Fundamentally, psychology as a whole, but
Freud’s psychoanalysis in particular: The desires,
our desires, our instincts and also the
great desires in life that we suppress
are not simply gone, they smolder
and can even turn against us.
So numerous neurotic illnesses are
attributed to the fact that people had to
suppress too many of their longings, lusts and
desires in life for too long. And he says that
that is also what's dangerous about this
Christian ideology, as he calls it.
All in all, this great hatred of the body
bothers him, because, as we have seen,
he saw from early on that everyone
is also a Dionysian and that's why
he says: "I am body completely and nothing else."
“Body am I”, with this
he contradicts the hostility to the body of the entire tradition,
including that of philosophy. This tradition says
we are primarily rational beings, animal rationale,
and that the body is the servant of the spirit,
which only carries out what the spirit decides. But it is
not like that. Nietzsche, by contrast, speaks
of the “great reason” of the body because he
says it would also be a complete illusion
to believe that our reason governs us,
our consciousness. Because - by the
way, today's scientists would confirm this - there has
been life for an incredibly long time. Scientifically
we would have to say, life has existed
for about three billion years -
three billion! - hardly imaginable. And
also the hominids, Nietzsche speaks of
the semi-animals, they've been around
forever. But they were in the woods in
hordes as hunters and gatherers. They weren't
conscious either. And only at the very end of
the history of our evolution did consciousness
arise at all. But we
still have that legacy within us. And that's why
it can't be taken away. He then also says:
"Once you were monkeys and even now Man
is more monkey than any monkey." That's
the tendency he has there.
But given that we lived
for billions of years only instinctively,
according to stimulus and reaction and desire,
including as protozoa and during the whole of
evolution, how did it come about
that today we have a consciousness
at all? - And even worse, a guilty
conscience? And then he wrote this famous
chapter in the 'Genealogy of Morals' about
the emergence of bad conscience.
And he says that
the whole madness came about at the
moment when people left the forests and
founded the first communities, villages,
kraals and then also states. Because
something bad happened within these
communities and states. There were
laws and rules. And now nobody was
allowed to harm anyone anymore.
But you had to suppress all the instincts
you had before, the anger, the attention, the aggression,
the running away. You know, in the forest, you
could still hear every cracking sound, you could
smell it, you knew “now I have to run away” if
you were threatened or if you were attacked while
hunting. We were sure in our instincts.
Nietzsche says we've now lost all these instincts.
The whole development of evolution has been negative.
Water used to carry us when we were still
in the water. Now our feet have to carry us.
And it was also a very negative step
when suddenly self-awareness arose through
the founding of the state. Because, he says:
"Suddenly all human beings’ instincts were invalidated
and hung up. I don't think there was ever
such a feeling of misery on earth" as
when suddenly the instincts were devalued.
And you know it is actually like this:
the instincts are devalued - and not
only devalued, they are taboo. So if we
get a choleric attack at work and
shout out loud because we're angry,
then everyone says: “But you're aggressive”.
Sure, says Nietzsche, because
the instinct is still there, but it can no longer
be lived out. These instincts have been hung up
and devalued. And now in the state, when
we live together in such large groups,
it is about something else: these
people, that is us, are
reduced to thinking, reasoning,
calculating, combining causes and effects,
these unfortunates: reduced to their consciousness,
to their poorest and most misguided
organ!" So all of a sudden we had
to rely on our poorest organ,
on our consciousness, and we thought,
and calculated whereas we’d been used
for many years, to being completely instinctive
throughout all of evolution . Now we
have this loss of instinct. At that
moment -- what happened? Then
he says: "All instincts that
are not discharged outwards turn
inwards". Now it's getting exciting.
Now he says: "Because we can't
for example, take food when we’re hungry” –
Small children still do it in the
shop. If you don't guard the shopping
trolley, they reach over and
get the chocolate, open it and eat it,
because they have instinctive confidence.
get the chocolate, open it and eat. Of course,
Later, of course, they have to learn that
things don’t work that way –.”then we
turn all our instincts inwards". Aggression too.
Aggression saved us for thousands of years
because we defended territories, conquered new
ones, because we fought against other hordes
but now we have to suppress this energy
of aggression
which is directed inwards now and leads
to self-punishment impulses. And that is
the origin of the bad conscience. So he
says: "The enmity t, the cruelty,
the desire for persecution, for change,
for destruction - all this directed against
the owner of such instincts: That is the
origin of the "bad conscience". The
penalties, he says, do the rest, insofar as we
know, of course, that if we don't follow the
rules of the state we will be punished. But
ultimately bad conscience is also
fed by our own energy, that we know
we shouldn't do that now and
keep ourselves in check with our own
energy. And the bottom line is: Both
consciousness and conscience are very
late phenomena in evolution, which
didn't exist at all for a long time and which ultimately
shouldn't play the decisive role in our lives either.
Rather, the decisive thing is,
says Nietzsche, that we still have
an enormous will - and we feel that in ourselves.
We have desires, we have longings, we have
needs and he doesn't just mean eating
and drinking. He says that all the needs,
longings and desires that we have result in our
wanting. Every human being has such a
will. And now we are already at the heart of the matter:
The will to power. Then he says: "This world: a
monster without beginning, without end, is the
will to power - and nothing more! And you
yourselves are also this will to power - and
nothing more!" How can he claim that this world,
a monster of power, is the will to power?
Is the world really the will to power?
To this he says: Yes, the whole world is the
will to power, and that is because:
Every plant grows according to the sun,
Extends itself, partly putting other plants in the shade,
which then extend themselves too
and do the same thing. But if
there is a little tree and a big one, the little one
usually dies or the one that grows faster
stays. So there is also an unconditional
will to live, to survive and to improve
oneself. Also in plants and even in chemistry.
He says when substances mix,
You remember that from chemistry class, then
The resulting substances change colour, they react
with each other. Either they mix or they
repel each other. But in any case,
says Nietzsche, forces interact. Forces are
at work in all of nature. That is why he says:
the whole of nature is a monster of power.
About the planets too he writes a nice sentence:
The supposed laws of nature are nothing
more than the balance of power. Well,
the fact that the planets attract each other and
have these orbits, that's calculated exactly
how much attraction one has on
the other, and that's how it levels
out. It's about power and forces –
and the same goes for people.
an interesting example of the first
living beings, by the way. At that
time there were already microscopes
and such techniques. They were
able to magnify things optically.
And then he says: The amoeba,
the smallest little animal, also has tiny hairs and wafts
around. As soon as the amoeba encounters
something organic, it encloses it.
And if ist likes it, then that gets
integrated into the amoeba, it eats it up, so
to speak. And this appropriation we have had in
nature since the beginning. So, the will to power and also
we ourselves as human beings, we are nothing other than
this will to power. And that's why he also says: "Everything
that happens can be reduced to the intention
of increasing power." But that's how it works even
now, he says, that we always affect others.
Increasing our power can also mean
hindering others in their own self-improvement. But there's no getting
around it. Therefore, he says: "Life always lives at the expense of
other life. Anyone who does not
understand this has not yet
taken the first step towards honesty." He says
we can't help it. For example, if you apply for
a job as a head of a department and get it,
then x colleagues have applied, they
won't get it and then they're sad. So, every success
comes at the expense of the failure
of others. Or the Olympic champion, who then
stands on the podium, with the wreath,
shining golden in the glory of victory, stands up there
because at the same time he darkens and shadows others
who are not up there. Nietzsche says we can't live
at all without affecting others. That's
not possible. And then he also has more subtle examples
that I find very exciting. For example, he says
that if two men fall in love with the same woman
or even three men,
and one gets her, then two others
will be left behind. Or one of his
most subtle examples, he was also a great
psychologist: mothers. An early childhood
phase is something interesting for him, because
he says mothers who, shall we say,
love one child more than the other or the
others, back then everyone had five or six,
they don't do it consciously. They are fair. They give
everyone the same amount. But
they can't help it, one being is
somehow closer to them. And the worst thing, he
says, is that the children sense it and that's why
it's not the mother's fault
for what she's doing. He says:
you finally have to think beyond
good and evil, which is the title of one of
his books: Beyond Good and Evil.
The mother who
just loves, subconsciously, one child a bit
more than another
it's not her fault  – not really –
if she always tries to be fair and just.
But the less loved child may
feel neglected and has problems dealing with it.
And that's why we can't avoid it: Life always
lives at the expense of other life,
That's how it is with us.
Another nice sentence from him is:
"The insects do not sting out of
malice, but because they also
want to live." So he means the
mosquitoes. And it's correct.
You always hear: Bssss! In reality,
what are they supposed to
do? Even if for us it's terror,
which is malicious, they
can't help it. And we too often cannot do otherwise.
And no one goes through life without
causing problems for others at some point. And because
that's the way it is, he says, because we're there
he says: "I judge the power of a will
by how much resistance,
pain, torture it endures and how
it manages to turn these things to its advantage."
He says we all have obstacles in life.
But we can use resistance as an opportunity
to grow and turn it to our advantage.
So our self-development, our will to
power, proceeds against resistance,
always in life. But he just values ​​an individual
according to whether the individual manages
to overcome the things that are against
him and to make them into his will. Now,
of course, one can say, and Nietzsche was also heavily
criticized for this, that there are no limits to this!
If everyone
Lives out their will to power,
then at some point enormous egoism will
emerge. Everyone develops their will to
power. What limits should it have
if not even pity is a limit,
if not even pity limits our egoism?
Where is the limit of the will to power?
Can you overpower others? Are you allowed to
kill others for the sake of your development and
your own higher goal? And
there he says. It can actually
be so. That’s quite radical - a radical thought
of Nietzsche’s. He says: It may be,
it may be, it is possible for each of us, "That something
is a hundred times more important than
the question of whether we are well or
badly off and consequently whether others
are well or badly off. In short; it may be that we have an end
for which no one hesitates to make human sacrifices."
So, it can actually be the case that, in in order to develop our highest goal
and our will to power, we should not consider
ourselves or others and should make the
highest sacrifices - including human sacrifices. Of
course, such quotations also brought Nietzsche
close to fascism. And you know, Mussolini too, he
really read Nietzsche and had huge monuments
erected for Nietzsche. And this was because, initially,
he recognized no limits to this principle.
But, ladies and gentlemen,
we're trying to look at it this in a non-ideological
way, without immediately
pushing it in any direction. And if you do this
you must be honest and say that sometimes you do
sacrifice yourself for a higher purpose. It doesn't
matter whether you feel good or bad about it,
nor how others feel. If necessary, we
must make human sacrifices.
Just think of the former German Chancellor,
the former Federal Chancellor Helmut
Schmidt. He got into a very difficult,
you could say tragic situation. Because the
Baader-Meinhof group were being held in prison,
some of whom had been accused of murder
several times. Then the terrorists who
some of them accused of multiple murders.
Then the Baader-Meinhof terrorists who
were still outside hijacked a Lufthansa plane
and also Hanns-Martin Schleyer, head of the
Confederation of German Industry, and said
they would release everyone provided
Ulrike Meinhof, Andreas Baader and the other
Jailed terrorists were released.
And this meant that
Helmut Schmidt and his cabinet faced
a very difficult decision. And he said,
no, we won't let them go, he had
the Lufthansa plane stormed. And that's
why Hanns Martin Schleyer was
executed, so to speak, killed by the terrorists.
And that's crazy, Schmidt even sat
next to Frau Schleyer at the
funeral. That was a really,
really hard time for him. But he said that
he would make that sacrifice again. So,
as you can see here, he had a higher goal,
a goal of the sort for the sake of which one
does not hesitate to make human sacrifices. He
had that goal. His goal was reasons of state. He
said that things will not work unless the rule of law
convicts perpetrators and brings them to justice.
let's set them free. Especially if they are murderers
who might even kill again. He says:
let's set them free. Anyway, if they are murderers
who might even kill again. Then he says
no, that's not possible. The higher goal in
this case is the rule of law. And our justice
must be above this release
and he would basically, well, what did he mean
when he said "sacrifice again" Hanns Martin Schleyer? -
he didn't want to sacrifice him, of course,
he deliberately risked this life and said he would do it
again. And by the way he also wrote
a note, a written document that he deposited
saying that if he himself were kidnapped
or Loki Schmidt, his wife, that they
must not be exchanged. He also deposited that.
So he also made the sacrifice for himself,
which he now asked for. Or he would have been
willing to make that sacrifice. So you see,
you can also interpret it that way. Of course,
Nietzsche not only extended his will to power
to the individual but also said that
it applies to large nations.
Great peoples in history have
also lived out their will to power,
which, for Nietzsche, is not a bad thing.
He says, for example: "Those big
hothouses for the strong, for the
strongest kind of man" –
"the strongest kind of man", here we see this
"strong and weak", which is why he is also
criticized a lot. "Those big hothouses for the strong
and for the strongest kind of man that
has ever existed, the aristocratic polities
in the manner of Rome and Venice
understood freedom exactly in the sense in which I
understand the word freedom: as something that one
has and that one does not have , that one wants, that
one conquers." So he has Rome in mind, ancient
Rome and Venice. These were communities that
used their freedom and their self-development
to conquer, to keep and to gain what they didn’t yet have
That's why Mussolini found Nietzsche
so great, because he also
wanted to revive ancient Rome and its old splendor.
But we'll see in a moment that Nietzsche wasn't
really interested in that. He also celebrates
Venice. And if you then read on,
he says, the northern Italian cities also
developed the will to power in a great way. And
I'll show you why right now. By the way,
he says: In the Renaissance, at that time,
when Venice and later Florence and those
northern Italian cities had this crazy power,
mankind took an enormous step forward.
He even claims that the Europeans of today
“remain at a level below the
Europeans of the Renaissance in terms of their values".
Well, they did something great
in the Renaissance. And he wasn't
concerned with the fact that Venice and its merchant fleet
powerfully controlled the entire Mediterranean region,
nor the Borgia ruling in Renaissance Italy
but essentially with the fact that in the
Renaissance an enormous act of human self-liberation
had taken place. Science flourished for the first time.
Doctors were allowed to dissect corpses. And for
the first time human beings were freed from
millennia-old medieval thinking. You
know, the artists, for example
Leonardo da Vinci or Michelangelo,
were also scientists. They
had a completely free, enlightened way of thinking. And
for the first time perspective was also painted. The
whole Middle Ages was only two-dimensional.
You could see the haloes there,
but they had no depth. That's when
it started, when perspective was introduced.
Then all the sciences blossomed.
This inspired Nietzsche.
Or Brunelleschi, who built his
huge dome. In the Renaissance
people liberated themselves. And the artists,
by the way, signed their works themselves.
Suddenly, beautiful naked bodies were
painted. It was much more Dionysian,
he says, the Renaissance. Because nudity was
completely forbidden in the Middle Ages.
And then of course, how should I put it,
they did something exciting. The
Renaissance artists simply said, yes,
we paint ancient things like that,
Botticelli's Venus, and of course such an ancient
goddess, Venus, has to be naked. And
he just liked this awakening.
He writes, for example, that:
"the Italian Renaissance contained the liberation
of thought, the disregard for authority,
enthusiasm for science, the unleashing of
the individual, a fervor of veracity."
enthusiasm for science, unleashing
So you see, for Nietzsche, "will to power"
doesn't necessarily mean huge conquests,
it's more about intellectual development,
artistic development.
And that brings us to our initial question
and our last big topic. How does one
do that? How can we develop ourselves?
What is this overman that
he recommends to us? "The gods are dead, now
we want the superman to live." But who or
what is this overman? And can those of us
gathered here also become “overmen”?
Let's look at that now; finally.
"The overman", says Nietzsche,
""is close to my heart, that is my first
and only thing and not the human being:
not ‘my neighbour’, not the poorest, not the
most suffering, not the ‘best’." And it's
interesting that he says that the overrman is
important to him and not the human being. And that
this overman is something different from his “neighbour”.
That’s actually clear, and not the poorest,
and not the most suffering either, that's what
we already know from Nietzsche, his,
how should I put it, negative assessment of
Christian heroes, that is, the hero on the cross,
Jesus on the cross is the most suffering or the
poorest. How should I say? The overman
of religions is the ascetic, like Buddha,
who withdraws, or just like Jesus, or
also the Franciscans and other mendicant orders,
who owned nothing but a rope around their stomachs
and a few robes. There was this ideal of the
denial of all property, of everything belonging
to this world. And this Nietzsche rejected.
That's not the overman. The overman is
not the ascetic. You know that Nietzsche had a lot in
common with Schopenhauer, and Schopenhauer says
you have to be as ascetic as possible. Nietzsche
says: no, no, the overman
is not the one who suffers, not the poorest, not
one’s needy “neighbour”, and - now it's getting exciting -
he is not even “the best”. Why not the best?
based on what we know from Nietzsche so far,
one would think that the overman is the strongest,
ergo also the best. But that is not what Nietzsche
means. It's not about the
overman’s being
a capitalist who is incredibly successful
in business, or a politician, or Alexander
the Great who conquers a huge empire. He
does not claim that “the best man” is
is the overman. He says: "The higher nature
of the great man lies in his incommunicability" –
this is interesting – “in his incommunicability,
not in the fact that the effects he produced
may have shaken the globe." So if the higher
nature of the great man leads to the overman,
this is not because he
he has a huge impact and shakes the whole world,
but rather in his incommunicability. What does he
mean by someone being “incommunicable”?
And why should that be considered a good quality:
that he cannot make himself understood?
But Nietzsche explains this very well.
He says it's ultimately about finding
our own inner higher idea, that is, our
innermost creative potential, our
innermost higher being. If we find that, then
we have to live it out. And then it doesn't matter
whether we are understood and can communicate.
We have to assert this idea all the same. And he writes,
many great writers and also painters,
they had something like that,
they did their thing, regardless of whether they
were understood. For example – this is
not by Nietzsche himself but I think
the example is quite good – Van Gogh,
Van Gogh was destitute all
his life. And everyone just
shook their heads at his pictures. Nobody
understood him because he painted
in a completely new way. He is one of the founding
fathers of Expressionism. When he saw a cornfield
with ravens overhead and a storm came
up, he painted it. It's totally spooky.
He was able to bring his mood,
his way of perceiving reality,
directly onto the canvas and this meant the end
of “idyllic” painting. And everyone said
“I’m not hanging stuff like that on my wall”.
So he encountered huge obstacles. No one
understood this new kind of fervent
painting at all. Or the sunflowers.
There you can see these sunflowers - beautiful
and great and powerful, vital. But you can
already see a few wilted leaves and you can see
this whole metamorphosis, can understand the
mortality and suffering of this flower.
This message is also in there. But that was
not understood at all at the time, this new realism on
the one hand, and on the other hand this direct way
of capturing his feelings just with these
dashed lines that he painted five times over.
And you know Van Gogh died destitute.
And today these paintings
are the most expensive paintings in the whole world.
Nothing else attracts such prices and Nietzsche would
say: “Sure! It shouldn't matter if we
get no recognition from others just now.
And it shouldn't matter if one day
we somehow become ridiculously rich
through what we do.” So it is
by no means the case that today he would say that
the “overmen” are the managers and the bankers.
He would consider them anything but overmen. He would
say: "Look at these superfluous ones!
They acquire riches and become poorer with it
- these impotent ones." You notice, then, what a
constantly shifting description he ultimately gives
of his “overman”. And he also adds:
"Passionate people think little of what others
think. Their condition elevates them
above vanity." That is also important to him.
Of course, a lot of this comes from his own life.
Because he himself, you know, was
destitute, so to speak. Nobody
read Nietzsche back then. They all
thought he was a nutcase.
Publishers stopped accepting his books
And, in desperation, he had to
accepting his books. Then, in desperation, he had to
print them himself. It was not until
towards the end of his life that
his work actually fell
on more fertile ground.
But he was ill already, so never experienced
it himself. But that's just, so to speak,
a sidelight. And he just says: "Everyone
has their good day, on which
they find a higher self." So that's what it’s all about
for him: that we find our higher self. He says
everyone has moments like that. "For example, a painter
should be appraised and honored for the highest vision that
he was able to see and depict."
And not whether
he was successful or anything. It
was important to Nietzsche that we
realize our innermost creative potential. And to be
completely free and to enter new spaces. This is, of course,
difficult to understand at first and also obscure.
In addition, he describes the overman in his
book Zarathustra. And Zarathustra is not
a conventional philosophical work.
It is a poetic work where he describes his
great prophet Zarathustra. At the beginning
of the book Zarathustra descends from the mountains
and tells the world what it should look like.
So he created his own prophet. And this
Zarathustra then tells us how the path
to the new human being should go. And
it can be argued that he is maybe
more concerned here with artists, geniuses,
philosophers etc. and not with ordinary folk
philosophers, etc. but I maintain that but I maintain that he also
has a few other quotes which show that
this is not just about geniuses. So here
he also writes: "Everyone has their good
day" and what I also find interesting, is that
in Zarathustra he gives us a hint, that I want to
end by passing on to you, that, on the way to the
overman, we have to go through three transformations.
I'll give you that hint now. "I shall name you three
transformations of the spirit”
spirit." So you have to go through three transformations
of the spirit: "How the spirit becomes
a camel, and the camel becomes a lion, and finally the lion
becomes a child." A very famous parable by Nietzsche.
So the spirit first becomes a camel, then the
camel becomes a lion, and finally the lion
becomes a child. Exciting - why the child? By the camel
he means – oh and by the way, this parable
clearly refers to two things at once: our
development as individuals and the history of mankind
i.e. the social moment –
Individually, the phase of the camel,
which we all go through, is that of our training
period, when we learn, when our parents,
our mentors, our teachers, place more and more
burdens on us. So the phase of the camel,
he says, is the patient, tolerant phase that we all
go through. We take on more and more knowledge,
more and more morals, more and more laws, more
and more patterns of behavior, etiquette, rules, etc.
This is the camel's phase in our youth.
Then comes the phase of the lion.
In the phase of the lion we shred
all this, we tear it up. We
free ourselves from the old dramas,
from the old traditions, from
everything our parents told us. That's
the phase of the lion. The lion tears
everything with his teeth. It's often interpreted
like this. For many, puberty is the time when you
liberate yourself. For some, however, it occurs
much later, in adulthood. For others, it
really doesn't come until the midlife crisis.
This doesn’t really matter. Let's leave that aside.
In terms of mankind as a whole he means: The phase of
The lion is this phase where mankind.... Sorry -
let's start with the camel. In the beginning we are all
believers. We live, so to speak, in humility and are
at ease in the religious worldview. He calls this whole
long phase the phase of the camel. But then,
how should I put it, the lion – and Nietzsche
didn't elaborate further but he could
mean the Enlightenment, where we
actually tear everything apart
and question it. So the beginning of
science and everything. But,
he says, we mustn't stop there.
We mustn't stop there with the
phase of the lion: it's not enough if we just
liberate ourselves, be it as individuals or as a species,
that is, from the point of view of the social situation.
He then says: now the transformation into
the playing child must come. And then he asks
an interesting question. He poses it in that slightly,
how should I put it, emotive and histrionic tone
that he adopts in Zarathustra, who is speaking to his disciples
and to his brothers. By the way, this prophet
Zarathustra is a great book, so it's
fun to read it and he says: "But tell me,
my brothers, what can the child
do that the lion couldn't do either? I mean, so far
it's been up to us. Yes, of course. The first phase
is the camel, then the lion, but why is this last great
transformation a transformation into a
playing child? With Nietzsche, one actually
expects that on the way to the overman the
last transformation will be into a huge monster
or an all-powerful dragon or the devil knows what.
No, for the last transformation, he asks: "What can
the child do that the lion couldn't do?" And
he replies: "Create new values,
the lion can't do that either: but
create freedom for yourself to create new things, that's what the
power of the lion is capable of". So the lion can only make room
for us to create something new. But he doesn't
set any new values yet. He doesn't create that
yet. And Nietzsche also says that most people at some
point in their lives succeed in freeing themselves
from their upbringing, their origins,
from all these things and all possible influences.
But the decisive thing is now: What do we do
with our freedom? what do we do with it? And
he says, sometimes – he wasn't very sociable,
Nietzsche, he tended to live alone –
sometimes friends visited him and, as
he writes very interestingly, everyone always
told him what they had emancipated and freed
themselves from, and what they’d finally left
behind them. But he was actually more interested
in what they’d become free for! Not in what they’d freed
themselves from, but why, how they were now
fulfilling their freedom. And he writes: "I want
to hear your ruling thoughts and not
that you have escaped a yoke. Free from what?
What does that matter to Zarathustra! Brightly
your eyes should tell me, free for what?" And that's
what it's all about, that in this phase of life we find out
what our own Dionysian creative potential might
fit us to do, so to speak. And this is why the transformation
into the child is important, into the
playing child. Now we can understand why.
Because in this phase after the liberation we
basically have to start from scratch. Basically ,
we have to go back into the world with
an open mind. And then he says: "The
child is innocence and forgetting, a new beginning,
a game, a wheel rolling out of itself, a first movement,
a holy yes-saying. Yes to the game, to the game
of creation." So, he's saying here, the child is
innocent, it is not bearing any burdens. And the
child has this holy ability to say yes to creativity.
You know how we could get into it
as children and play passionately. We
have to acquire this again. And he doesn't just mean
the really great artists. But, of course, there
is also a quote from Picasso, I think, that fits
very well at this point. Even Picasso
had the big problem of having left behind,
how should I put it, the whole tradition
through his abstract painting. For 2000 years
people painted things as copies and suddenly he
painted abstractly. And he didn't dare to do
that right away. And Picasso once said:
"It takes a long time to become young."
I think that's a nice quote,
which basically means exactly what Nietzsche
said. It takes a long, long time
to grow young. And for him, being young
simply meant seeing things the way
he had seen them before developing prejudices.
And then he got into this abstraction. And that's
what Nietzsche is all about. Hence this third transformation
into the playing child. And some say that, by the
overman, he meant individual outstanding
personalities who come along from time to time.
But I think it's permissible to consider
whether that might not also apply to us all.
Nietzsche has, for example, the aphorism: "Maturity.-
For a man means having rediscovered the seriousness
that one had as a child when playing."
Maturity for a man means
having rediscovered the seriousness that
one had as a child when playing."
The same goes for women, of course. Maturity
for a woman would also mean finding the
seriousness again, to passionately get
involved in such a game, to immerse
oneself in it, to lose oneself in it. These are the things
Nietzsche cares about. These are the steps on the way to the
higher self. Basically, what I'm saying,
what I'm claiming, is that this “overman” idea is one
big self-actualization story, “coming-out”
story that he's telling us. Good,
but there is a big obstacle when
we now think about whether this
would also be an option for us. Nietzsche writes himself
about this great obstacle, namely time. He says:
"Everyone still falls today, as they have at all times,
Into one or another of two classes, namely:
into slaves and free people. Because whoever
does not have two thirds of his day for himself
is a slave, whatever else he is:
statesman, merchant, civil servant, scholar."
So if you don't have at least two-thirds of your
day to yourself, you're a slave, regardless
of whether you're a minister or a businessman,
you're a slave. And I often think to myself,
ladies and gentlemen, when I come
home in the evening and I'm
exhausted after an 8-hour day, that I
have no more creative thoughts in me. You turn the
TV on and off. And what Nietzsche is saying is that
this free time is almost a basic human right we should demand
You really should have two-thirds of the
day to yourself. Only then can we tap our
full potential and pass it on to society.
That would mean, let's assume we get
up at 9, well let's say 8 a.m., and say
from 8 a.m. to 8 p.m., that would be
the part of the day where we’re really
fit and awake. And two thirds of that, that
would now be twelve hours. That would be two
thirds, if I calculate it correctly, we basically need,
So we should really only
work four hours a day. What he's
proposing here is the four-hour work-day.
…For example - yes, absolutely…
The circle will close even more now,
because I would like to bring things to a close, so to
speak. So Nietzsche says, I summarize:
God is dead. The “new idols”, capitalism, socialism,
nationalism, racism, are not things we should worship.
we don't worship. That would be wrong. Only
the small minds do that, who are only capable
of developing false feelings instead of
developing their own lives themselves. And
Rather, we must try to develop ourselves determinedly
after the death of God, and to unfold
our higher inner being. And here Nietzsche
gives us two more hints. On the
one hand, it is important that we become more Dionysian
again, that is, that we live with relish, that
we let the Dionysian principle that has been suppressed
for centuries, the creative Dionysian, have
its say again. Although I have to tell you:
He also says that there are some people
who have more Dionysian qualities and some
who have more Apollonian ones. I myself
ran a film school for years and the Dionysians –
that is, my students training to be film directors –
were very difficult people. Because they
draw from their innermost being and then they are
no longer capable of self-criticism. Because that
comes from a source that is beyond criticism.
With the Apollonians, who think logically,
you can discuss things with them. It's about
arguments. The Dionysians are difficult.
But that's just a digression now. And
of course they have to be like that, the creative
people, you have to say that again. They have
to rely on what they have recognized
as innermost, highest. But Nietzsche
actually advises us to consider, on our way in life,
our Dionysian principle once again,
to respect our intuition and secondly – which
I actually find quite beautiful –
this image, this thought that
we should perhaps try to
become a playing child again. And so I would
like to close with a quote from Nietzsche:
"One must still have chaos in oneself in order to be able
to give birth to a dancing star." Thank you very much.